ich begrüße sie herzlich zur sternstunde
religion
auf uns kommt nach der akuten phase der
korona pandemie eine welle der
psychischen und sozialen leiden zu das
sagt der psychiater thomas idee toll was
er im einzelnen damit meint darüber
spreche ich mit ihm in der nächsten
halben stunde
schön dass sie da sind ja schon nah dann
kredite einfordern
er soll die universität basel hat vor
wenigen tagen eine online-umfrage
publiziert da gab rund die hälfte der
befragten an sich gestresst dazu fühlen
als vor der korona krise gehören sie zu
dieser hälfte
es hat beide aspekte also es gibt teile
meines lebens da ist mein stresspegel
sehr viel höher
aber es gibt auch teile da ist
eigentlich paradoxe weise was deine
entspannung da wo ist die entspannung
ich habe weniger referate das heißt ich
bin vielmehr in interlaken aber mehr
zeit da und auch etwas mehr freizeit
sie sind ja chefarzt der berner
oberländer spitäler meiringen und
interlaken und als wir vor zwei monaten
zum ersten mal kontakt hatten
da haben sie gesagt sie seien jetzt
gerade in den pandemie stadt berufen
worden was natürlich aufgabe pandemie
starb ging es wirklich darum die ganze
spitalgruppe auf diese veränderte
situation vorzubereiten das war damals
eine ganz schwierige aufgabe weil man
wirklich nicht wusste was kommt da auf
uns zu wie sahen alle diese bilder von
bergamo und daten durch interlaken wird
auch bergamo das heißt wir haben eine
intensivpflege station hochfahren müssen
innerhalb von nur ein paar tagen da war
es um die pflege enorm gefordert wie bei
uns in der psychiatrie gegen strand um
unsere angebote umzustellen also
umzustellen aus telefonberatung video
beratung ein anderes notfallsystem das
ging aber relativ gut weil wirklich alle
mitarbeitenden haben wirklich so dieses
teamgefühl kann da enorm zum tragen
das heißt sie haben während dieser zeit
auch weiterhin ihre psychisch
beeinträchtigten patientinnen und
patienten betreut wie sie sagen über
videotelefonie oder telefon
was waren da ihre erfahrungen jetzt und
auch als in wochen eigentlich sehr gut
wobei ich schon immer relativ viel mit
telefon und video gearbeitet hatte also
menschen die bei mir persönlich in
behandlung sind die mussten sich da
bereits damit abfinden dass ich manchmal
wurde eine stimme am anderen ende des
telefons bin für viele menschen war es
etwas eine schwelle die sie zuerst
überwinden mussten und dann die
erfahrung machen konnten ja eigentlich
so groß anders ist es gar nicht und es
gibt auch themen die kommen fast besser
leben besprechen wenn man sich da nicht
gegenüber sitzt und keinen augenkontakt
hat das auch da eine sehr gemischte
erfahrung aber ich glaube es freuen sich
jetzt alle auch wieder zu uns in unserer
gebäude kommen zu können für die
behandlung so etwas wie ein zogen fertig
sind also dieses diese müdigkeit
erscheinung die sich bei gewissen leuten
einstellt über videotelefonie den
kontakt zu den menschen herzustellen das
spüren sie weniger das spüre ich schon
auch wobei man heute jetzt ja auch
selber weiß was passiert da überhaupt
eben dass unser team wirklich enorm viel
mehr arbeiten muss wenn schon nur die
mimik eine halbe sekunde verzögert ist
dass da wirklich etwas passiert bei uns
das eben auch sehr viel mehr energie
benötigt haben sich in ihren spitälern
jetzt die psychiatrischen fehler in den
letzten wochen erhöht die fallzahlen
es hat sich verändert und auch da wieder
das ganze spektrum das die eso das
spannende es gibt auch menschen die
haben auch wiederum fast etwas eine
solidarität gespürt so im sinne ich
glaube jetzt versteht vielleicht die
allgemeinheit mal die es mir eigentlich
tag für tag geht dass man plötzlich
angst hat wenn man aus dem eigenen haus
hinausgeht
das kennen viele hat vorher kannten das
viele nicht und plötzlich merken dass
alle dass es irgendwie unangenehm war
das erste mal wieder einkaufen zu gehen
um nicht zu wissen ja die kassiererin
ist die jetzt in fact regen oder nicht
ist das gefährlich für mich da ich hoffe
es was ich bin ja auch präsident der pro
mente sana da ist schon auch die
hoffnung dass man das irgendwie auch
umsetzen kann also an die stigma
damit es wirklich die bevölkerung
vielleicht mehr verständnis entwickelt
für menschen mit einer psychischen
belastung
die stiftung pro mente sana hat ja jetzt
in dieser zeit auch ihr angebot
ausgeweitet auch auf telefon und video
und auch auf ein beratungstelefon auch
eingerichtet gab es da vermehrt anfragen
ja da war wirklich natürlich haben die
die beratungszeiten verdoppelt und die
werden wirklich ausgenutzt was man da
vor allem auch mit ist die beratungen
die sind komplexer geworden
es ist so diese mischung für viele ist
die finanzielle absicherung plötzlich
gefährdet wenn ich alleine ziehen bin
drei kinder und ich habe ein coiffeur
geschäft dass das war eine wirklich ganz
schwierige situation und ist es immer
noch
dann auch diese begrenzung des wohnraums
das ging auch wieder in beide richtungen
es gibt menschen die halten sich im
norden isoliert also wird alleine lebt
und homeoffice dann noch machen musste
das war wirklich eine schwierige
situation keinen direkten menschlichen
kontakt mehr das macht einfach etwas mit
uns oder don't er wiederum dichte
stresst die kleine wohnung mit drei
schwierigen kinder die einfach kindes
sind das wird plötzlich zur belastung im
lock down also das sind so faktoren die
hinein gespielt haben
wir hatten auch relativ viele telefonate
beispielsweise von kindern mit
hochbetagten eltern also mein eigenes
fahrrad bis 82 meine mutter verstarb
noch vor nicht langer zeit verdienen
natürlich eine ganz schwierige situation
noch sind diese trauerphase alleine in
einer wohnung ohne direkten kontakt das
vor deinem auch ausgeben
das heißt also schon menschen ohne
psychische einschränkungen haben diese
zeit als sehr belastend empfunden da
frage ich mich wie steht es denn um all
jene menschen die schon eine psychische
vorerkrankung haben wie geht es den
dänen in dieser zeit eben auch da gibt
es unterschiedliche erfahrungen also es
gibt menschen eben die haben dich sich
eine verschlechterung erlebt weil so die
strukturen die sich getragen haben ich
habe jemanden geht die mit in die
universitätsbibliothek dort hatte sorgen
losen kontakt zu menschen das plötzlich
weggefallen für ihn ganz wichtig das war
es ein eckpfeiler der hatte dann
menschen mit angsterkrankungen die haben
oft damit zu kämpfen dass die ängste zu
gehen ob man haben und für die ist oft
jetzt gerade auch eigentlich nicht der
lock down war das schwierige sorgen
jetzt die lockerung der maßnahmen wohl
nichts mehr so klar ist und auch die
menschen sich nicht mehr so
diszipliniert an die maßnahmen halten
also da gibt es menschen die haben jetzt
vor allem sehr viel mehr ängste menschen
mit depressionen hatten frau mit der
einsamkeit zu kämpfen eben diese
isolation nie mehr kommt mir niemand
kommen körperlich nahe das kann für
solche menschen wirklich auch ein was
sehr schwierig sein
und dann natürlich auch das thema gewalt
ist ein thema die roten gerade häufig
auch menschen die opfer von gewalt sind
häusliche gewalt die in der gleichen
beziehung immer noch sind sie haben
plötzlich keine fluchtwege mehr gehabt
wenn es zu hause wieder eskaliert ist
es wurde ja zu beginn dieser
einschränkende maßnahmen prognostiziert
dass die häusliche gewalt wahrscheinlich
massiv zunehmen würde
zumindest was die polizei zahlen oder
die rückmeldungen an die polizei jetzt
angeht hat sich das aber scheinbar nicht
dermaßen erhärtet oder das ist so das
sieht man sehr klare unterschiede man im
internationalen vergleich oder die
initialen zahlen die kommen ja aus
buchen wo man diese vervierfachung sei
und das sieht man jetzt auch in england
wo die locker und sehr viel strenger ist
oder wir haben wirklich die möglichkeit
jederzeit raus zu können und die zeit
draußen ist nicht beschränkt das war in
madrid beispielsweise nicht möglich also
wenn man nicht aus den eigenen vier
wänden kann und die situation eskaliert
dann wird es gefährlich für alle
beteiligten das heißt wir haben das in
der schweiz vorausschauend auf eine
bessere art gelöst als als andere länder
auf eine typisch schweizerisch stemme
sich der art und weise haben wir das
gemacht
das thema unser nachteil wenn sich jetzt
soll allmählich eine sogenannte
normalisierung einstellt oder wir
zurückgehen zu
ein zustand den wir vielleicht vorher
hatten stellt sich jetzt bei ihnen
langsam entspannt ein
oder sehen sie eher mit banger in die
nächsten wochen und monate
es gibt eine gewisse entspannung aber es
ist immer noch enorm viel ungewissheit
da niemand von uns weiß wie die
situation im sommer wirklich sein wird
wie sie im herbst sein wird wir wissen
auch nicht wo stehen wir in einem jahr
ich denke die wünschen uns alle dass wir
möglichst eigentlich zum zustand zurück
gehen und so ein paar sachen die wir
jetzt aus eher positiv erlebt haben
sogar mitnehmen können
das wäre das aus ihrer sicht gerade so
diese ruhe in unserer gesellschaft die
wahl schon ändern nach außen orientiert
außen stimulation glaube ich wenig
menschen auf dieser welt die so viel
kultur konsumieren die aber auch so viel
reisen und jetzt glaube ich war
bayern.de fokus etwas möglichen innen
gerichtet was mache ich jetzt mit mir
selbst in den eigenen vier wänden mit
weniger möglichkeiten
ich glaube ist auch eine chance da etwas
verändern zu können dauerte denn diese
einschränkende zeit genug lange dass
sich die menschen auf sich selbst
zurückgeworfen fühlen und sich mit sich
selbst auseinandersetzen wenn ich mit
den meisten menschen gesprochen habe es
gerade die die alleine lebten bei denen
passierte das innerhalb von ein paar
tagen das ging ganz schnell in eine
familie denke ich dauerte es etwas
länger aber auch da sagen mir die
meisten es hat bei unserer familie hat
sich irgendetwas verändert und zum teil
eben auch sehr positiv wirklich mehr
dieses familiengefühl bietet wir haben
ja im meer oder in der stadt also eine
stressreaktion da gibt es diese diese
tod stelle flex oder die flucht reaktion
aber es gibt eben auch eine soziale
reaktion also unsere hormone werden
aktiviert oder wenn das das haus brennt
sollten wäre ja nicht nur aus dem haus
rennen wir sollten uns auch noch daran
erinnern die kinder mitzunehmen
deshalb haben wir eben auch soziale
hormone deaktiviert werden in einer
solchen krise und die bieten eben auch
eine chance sie haben eben gesagt die
diese situation hat bei menschen mit
psychischen vor belastungen die die
krankheitssymptome zum teil eher
verstärkt kann es dann auch sein dass er
eine krisensituation psychische krisen
auslöst wir wissen dass aus japan hatte
vor sechs sieben jahren als diese
zunahme war mit dem reaktorunglück der
haben psychische belastungen um 25
prozent zugenommen
also diese wirklich gravierende
veränderung auch eben mit großen
finanziellen konsequenzen haben auch
viele menschen die eine bäckerei
betrieben haben haben diese verloren das
hat auswirkungen auf die psyche und kann
auch krankheit verursachen oder auslösen
lassen sie uns noch über die problematik
der suchtmittel sprechen
in den letzten tagen kursierten immer
wieder meldungen dass der alkoholkonsum
beispielsweise bei einzelnen
personengruppen gestiegen ist insgesamt
aber wahrscheinlich eher zurückgegangen
ist erklärt man das
ich denke es hat auch die mitte
verfügbarkeit zu tun oder bei uns wird
doch eine relativ große alkoholmenge
wird eben in restaurants in gartenbeizen
oder den baus komm her konsumiert und
das ist weggefallen
dh der aufwand jetzt eben einkaufen zu
gehen und sie spezifische agro
einzukaufen das ist ein größerer aufwand
also das heißt ich denke die
gelegenheitstrinker die haben eher
weniger konsumiert menschen mit einem
problematischen alkoholkonsum wo der
alkoholkonsum klar eine emotions
regulative wirkung hatte hatte hierzu
genommen
das heißt immer emotional regulativ wie
wirkt alkohol auf stress kurzfristig
entspannen
aber ich denke das kennen die meisten
wenn man am abend etwas über den durst
trinkt dann hat das eine entspannende
wirkung
am nächsten morgen ist aber eigentlich
der stresspegel bereits erhöht
und man ist dünnhäutigen man verträgt
stress mit der zeit schlecht also
menschen die den alkohol abhängig werden
die haben ein die haben große mühe mit
stress umzugehen da braucht es nur eine
kleine stress menge und für sie weg des
bereits als wäre es völlig nicht
handelbar
in ihrer erfahrung jetzt als psychiater
kommen die menschen in solchen
situationen auf sie zu und sagen ich
habe jetzt in den vergangenen wochen
vermehrt zum alkohol gegriffen
wir sind mehr die familienangehörigen
die sich da melden wir haben ja bei uns
im oberland eine familien zentrierte art
zu behandeln also bei uns kommt es nicht
darauf an ob jetzt der ehemann der eben
zu viel trinkt sich meldet oder die 19
jährige tochter die sich so gemacht um
den vater wir schauen da immer das
system an das hilft da etwas in der
regel ist es aber das umfeld das sich
zuerst die sorgen macht sie sagen sie
rechnen jetzt in den nächsten wochen und
monaten mit einer erhöhten sozialen und
psychologischen belastung was denken sie
wird es auch in diesem bereich maßnahmen
geben werden damit diese kurve
abgeflacht wird so wie wir jetzt über
wochen gehört haben wir müssen die
fallzahlen der virus erkrankten
abflachen bisher war die prävention im
bereich psychischer gesundheit
eigentlich wenig thema also wir wissen
alle was wir körperlich tun müssen
ablehnte bereich auch ja was kann ich
machen will meine psychische gesundheit
ist in der schweiz immer noch eine
relativ neues thema
also ich denke da sind wir gefordert da
viel mehr zu kommunizieren tipps zu
geben und die bevölkerung zu
sensibilisieren dass sie auf weiß auf
was sie achten muss sprechen wir gleich
darüber was sind denn die maßnahmen wie
halten wir uns denn psychisch gesund da
könnte ich natürlich jetzt vier stunden
darüber erzählen so haben wir nicht sein
aber dann aber gerne an die die
wichtigsten empfehlungen die sie jetzt
hier geben können also jetzt sind wir
noch relativ akuten phase da haben ja
viele menschen gemerkt dass sie so den
tagesrhythmus verloren haben und dass
sie vieles verloren haben dass ihnen
geholfen hat mit stress umzugehen
oder ich selbst zum beispiel ich gehe
gerne in die berge und ich gehe gerne in
die sauna beides war es so gerade nicht
mehr möglich und ich musste mir
überlegen ja wie kann ich das ersetzen
mit den jetzigen maßnahmen und ich werde
das laufend anpassen müssen
daneben habe ich schon gesagt ja in
diese in eine krisensituation das in
bindung soll moniz sind ganz wichtig
also beziehungen und da muss man
wirklich einen fokus legen weil wir
hatten alle plötzlich wenige so auch
ihre oberflächliche kontakte
normalerweise wenn ich ins büro gehe da
sehe ich zwölf personen war ich kurz
einen schwarz abhalte und das musste ich
ebenfalls ersetzen aber eben auch
wirklich zeit resultieren vielmehr
intensive gespräche um die ganze krise
zu verarbeiten und jetzt auch dieser
nächsten schritte vorzubereiten das sind
so wichtige punkte sie haben als erstes
genannt diese anpassungsfähigkeit also
schnell aus der situation zu reagieren
und zu akzeptieren was ist jetzt nicht
mehr möglich und gleich überzugehen zu
dem was eben möglich ist
nun haben aber nicht alle menschen diese
fähigkeit wie sie jetzt gerade
geschildert haben
ich bin gleichwohl eigentlich sehr
positiv überrascht also unsere
bevölkerung hat eigentlich eine relativ
gute resilienz sehr viele menschen die
haben etwas zeit benötigt heißt residenz
des events heißt widerstandsfähigkeit
also mit den witterungen des lebens
möglichst gut umgehen zu können weil
krisen gehören ja zu unserem leben es
gibt eine studie die hat das mag erzählt
wir haben durchschnittlich elf größere
krisen während unserer lebenszeit und
deshalb macht es auch sinn dass wir
eigentlich auf krisen vorbereitet sind
und ein gewisses werkzeug bereits bei
geburt oder dann in der kindheit
mitgeliefert bekommen die wir eigentlich
krisen meistern können
und das sieht man bei vielen menschen
dass die gar nicht so hilflos reagierten
sondern einfach etwas zeit brauchten
aber dann so einen guten weg für sich
fanden präsident sie haben es gerade
gesagt wie dem kindesalter angelegt
warum manche kinder trotz widriger
lebensbedingungen resilienz entwickeln
was ihnen
hilft und was sie stärkt dazu finden sie
weitere informative beiträge auf unserer
internetseite
wir werden das bei ihnen ihre kindheit
her idee wie sind sie aufgewachsen
ich bin im grenzgebiet vom emmental im
oberaargau aufgewachsen für die damalige
zeit sehr durchschnittlich mein vater
arbeitete für den bund meine mutter war
früher zu hause hat dann bei der spitex
so jede berufung gefunden
im bereich der spiritualität religion
bin ich denke ich auch für die damalige
zeit sehr durchschnittlich aufgewachsen
das reformierte kirche wo ich denke ich
würde es so formulieren der bereich der
wirklich der spiritualität kam da etwas
zu kurz also ich habe als kind damals
nicht bei uns verstanden was eigentlich
der inhalt ist
ich habe das gebäude gekannt und ich
habe die formen bekannt und die riten
und was würden sie heute sagen was
spielt qualität ist man braucht den
begriff zwar schnell man hat intuitiv
eine ahnung was das heißen könnte aber
versuchen diesmal für sich darzulegen
was es heißt die die qualität also ich
denke als menschen haben wir eine
gewisse unruhe in uns wir sind suchen
die versuchen irgendwie einen 7 zu
finden warum diese welt funktioniert wie
sie ist und spiritualität kann heißen
dass man da diese ruhe findet also diese
innere fels der einem hilft in
krisenzeiten den schwierigen zeiten eben
gerade auch wenn ich selbst psychisch
erkrankte oder in einem umfeld etwas
passiert ist das etwas sowie ein
wegweiser der mir einfach sehr helfen
kann
sie sind ja auch als tracking leiter
unterwegs sieht machen willst trackings
und führen dabei gruppen in die wüste
des oman dort was machen sie dort sitzt
der gruppe wir schreiben sie schreiben
ja das ist eine wunderbare erfahrung und
mein lieblingshobby und das ist deine
für mich ein ganz wichtig rang in meinem
jahr diese zeit in der wüste
das heißt wir nehmen menschen eine bunte
gruppe in die wüste
und es geht darum die die technik der
achtsamkeit oder die praxis der
achtsamkeit und die wüste geeignet sich
sehe dazu weil das eine reduktion ist
ein es ist eine relative ruhe von außen
und da wird aber auch innerlich sehr
unruhig in den ersten paar wüsten tagen
da ist nichts still im kopf sondern da
kreisen die gedanken enorm
lokal ist wirklich die seele über hunde
themen und damit derzeit kommt so eine
uhr ein
wir sind ein paar bilder und können uns
dabei natürlich sehr gut vorstellen
diese umgebung auf menschen wirkt die
gewohnheitsmäßige trubel und unruhe und
hektik den alltag normalerweise finden
wenn sie wenn sie nachts in der wüste
sind und den sternenhimmel betrachten
was geht ihnen dabei durch den kopf
es freuen sich ja immer alles so drauf
ich sagen auch hier bieten kein fünf
sterne hotel an sondern 1000 sterne
hotel mit dem wüsten himmel und dann
sind die meisten überrascht dass das am
anfang eigentlich angst auslöst wenn man
so alleine in der wüste ist und so
diesen riesigen händler sieht und dann
wechselt das wirklich so in ein gefühl
für ein teil von einem großen ganzen zu
sein dieses ganze universum wirklich
wahrzunehmen und zu melken ich gehöre
dazu ich bin ein ganz kleiner teil ob
ich bin ein teil von diesem großen
ganzen und das erleben die meisten
wirklich aus tiefes wunderschönes
erlebnis
aber das könnte man auch hier haben das
kann man auch bei uns haben aber in
einer stadt zürich ist das etwas
anspruchsvolleres in der wüste ist es
etwas einfacher diese erfahrung zu
machen
aber die hatten für die auszeit ging es
in den bergen angeboten wo das natürlich
genauso gut kann aber man kann das auch
in oerlikon machen nehmen die menschen
die mit ihnen auf diese reise gehen
diese erfahrungen mit und können sie sie
dann umsetzen wenn sie wieder im alltag
sind das etwas vom wichtigsten oder
beides die achtsamkeit da gibt es ja
diese strukturelle achtsamkeit wo man
wirklich übungen macht wo man
sich für eine gewisse zeit 15 minuten
einfach nur auf den eigenen atem
konzentriert und dann gibt es so
genannte alltags achtsamkeit wo man
beispielsweise eben in der wüste muss
man häufig den koffer packen oder den
rucksack und man diese kleine übung
verwendet um achtsam zu sein wirklich im
hier und jetzt zu sein
und dann gibt es noch die komplexe auch
zum teil wo man das eigentlich möglichst
so viel wie möglich den ganzen tag macht
und bei der achtsamkeit eben da geht es
ja sehr um dieses im hier und jetzt sein
das heißt also wenn ich unter der dusche
bin dass ich nicht darüber nachdenken
wie war das gestern an dieser sitzung
oder das telefonat mit meiner frau hatte
doch etwas anderes sein sollen oder dass
man bereits in der zukunft etwas plan
sondern man ist einfach nur unter der
dusche
aber es gibt einen noch fast wichtigen
teil der achtsamkeit was wir ja ganz
häufig machen ist dass wir neben uns
stehen und uns ständig überlegen ja wie
machst du das gerade jetzt dieses
interview die dickste wohl könntest du
das irgendwie besser machen also dass
wir uns ständig bewährten beurteilen und
versuchen sachen zu optimieren
heute wissen wir das ist den orden
anstrengend von der biologie herbei das
wohl gedacht das wird als vielleicht
zehn minuten pro tag machen in unserer
optimierungs gesellschaft die meisten
die machen das zehn stunden 1200 total
und wenn man die sozialen medien
anschaut pakets ja nur noch um das diese
selbstbeurteilung bzw
das überlegen was denken wo man werde
jetzt über das bild das ich gerade
gepostet habe das wäre also das ist an
die achtsamkeit und bei der achtsamkeit
geht es wirklich darum wirklich bei sich
zu bleiben und nicht über sich
nachzudenken wie sind sie überhaupt zum
achtsamkeit thema gekommen
ich bin wie viele menschen in der
psychiatrie über meine therapie
ausbildung dazu gekommen
die psychiatrie die hatte früher die
erfasst so etwas anti spirituelles also
spiritualität war kein thema in meinen
ausbildungen und dann hat man irgendwie
gelegt aber dass er diese
kognitive verhaltenstherapie dass die
auch etwas mechanistische hatte und
irgendwie die menschen doch nicht ganz
in ihrem kern erfasste und dann haben
sich bewusst damit befasst wie kann man
die qualität wirklich in die therapie
einfließen zu lassen und so kam auch zum
kite in die psychotherapie und das war
dann so bin ich zur achtsamkeit oder
damals mein fels in den usa bekommen und
das war so wirklich ein es war nicht mal
ein aha erlebnis das ging noch schneller
als die drei buchstaben ich habe den
etwas passieren die zu mir und habe mich
sehr fasziniert sie haben eben auch
erwähnt gerade im kontext dieser krise
wie wichtig es ist und ich habe das auch
von anderen psychologen psychiatern
gelesen wie wichtig es ist dass man in
ausnahmesituationen eine struktur eine
tagesstruktur routine beibehält wenn die
äußeren strukturen aber gerade
wegbrechen ist er das ungeheuer
schwierig ungekannte gedanke dass
religiöse tagesstrukturen eigentlich die
menschen über jahrhunderte geprägt haben
und bei uns in europa sind diese
tagesstrukturen weggebrochen
kann es sein dass wir hier gerade
erfahren wie wichtig oder wie bedeutsam
dieser verlust von religiösen strukturen
in unserem alltag ist jetzt gerade in
dieser zeit
ich denke schon man sieht ja auch jetzt
wieder sehr viele online angebote eben
gerade auch im spirituellen bereich oder
wenn ich jetzt wieder zurück in den oman
die dort wird beispielsweise die die
fünf täglichen gebete werden sie mit
achtsamkeit verbunden also für sie ist
das ganz klar das ist fünfmal pro tag
habe ich meine zehn minuten wo ich auch
zombie eine klein kleines innehalten im
tag warschau wo ich gerade bin ich
verbunden mit einem großen ganzen
es ist ja auch auffallend gewesen dass
die strukturen wie die weltlichen sowie
wöchentlich ein fußballspiel gehen oder
in ein konzert gehen oder auch große
ereignisse wie eine olympiade die jetzt
wegbrechen dass die im gegensatz zu den
religiösen feste neben ersatzlos
gestrichen sind hingegen die religiösen
feste wir hatten das christliche
osterfest wir hatten das fischerfest
acht fest wir befinden uns inmitten des
islamischen fastenmonats wäre nicht
denkbar gewesen diese ereignisse zu
verschieden verschieben oder sogar
ausfallen zu lassen kragen religiöse
strukturen letztlich doch besser als
weltlicher ich würde das vielleicht
nicht so absolut formuliert es ist ja
immer auch sehr unterschiedlich für
einzelne menschen aber für viele
menschen ist das wirklich ein tragendes
wichtiges element und das heißt das
jetzt für eine gesellschaft die sich
zunehmend säkularisierten religiös
empfindet und die eigentlich das
loslassen oder das abstoßen der
religiösen zwänge als einen fortschritt
betrachtet es ist natürlich so die
werden wir jetzt unsere kultur anschauen
bei uns hat religion abgenommen hingegen
spiritualität ist ja gleich wohl ein
thema und ich glaube da sind die noch so
auf der suche ja was heißt das jetzt
oder es gibt ja ich arbeite im berner
oberland bei uns sind die reichen sehr
verbreitet die wiederum sei bewusst
religion und spiritualität verbunden
hafen verbunden mit einer starken
gemeinschaft
was ich denke wir sind halt in einer
selten realistischen gemeinschaft wo es
verschiedene lösungen geben wird bleiben
die spiritualität wirklich diese
persönliche suche nach dem großen ganzen
das ist etwas das die schweiz hebe weckt
unsere bevölkerung und ich denke durch
dieses wirklich völlig unerwartete
krisenhafte innehalten
ich glaube wir werden uns vielleicht
weniger und den dinos erinnern können
sondern eben wirklich an diese zeit und
plötzlich passiert ist in unserem leben
das geht etwas auslösen
wo ich denke schon dass das dazu führen
wird dass die spielt weil es wichtiger
werden wird wenn sie jetzt zwei haupt
erkenntnisse für sich heraus greifen
würden aus dieser zeit
welche sind das
es sind zwei sachen der seite ist
wirklich nicht auf einen sehr hektischen
sehr schönen sehr vielfältigen
arbeitstag und auch mein privatleben ist
zielpunkt ich pendler zwischen england
und der schweiz und in der krise merken
wie sehr beziehungen tragen die führen
bei uns in den psychiatrischen diensten
zu dritt und sie haben jetzt immer diese
krisensitzungen auf einem rasen vor
einem gebäude abgehalten das waren auch
sehr schöne momente dieses zu dritt
dieses zusammentragen
genau das gleiche die ich in der familie
leben zum beispiel die beziehung zu
meinem vater der jetzt sehr alleine ist
das sind sehr wichtige sachen dass ein
noch ein geschäft merken wie wichtig das
ist und das andere ist wirklich auch
eben nicht reise ja in rom gerne ich sie
sehr gerne neues militärisch langweilig
und ich bin schon auch jemand der recht
nach außen fixiert ist und sehr viele
stimulation sucht und jetzt mal welchen
halt wenn das mal einfach weg fällt es
gibt auch wirklich ein schönes
innenleben bei mir und allen andern dass
es sich zu erkunden lohnt dann wünschen
wir ihnen ein guter innere reise wie
auch unseren zuschauerinnen und
zuschauern
ganz herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch
hier trifft meine kollegin barbara
bleisch gleich ebenfalls einen
psychiater besser bekannt als
flugpionier und abenteurer bertrand
piccard
er ist gast in der sternstunde
philosophie nächste woche spricht meine
kollegin olivia berlin mit deborah feld
merken
sie gehörte bis zu ihrem 23 geburtstag
einer ultraorthodoxen jüdischen gemeinde
in brooklyn an
in ihrem buch unorthodox das auch als
vorlage für die gleichnamige netflix
terry dient beschreibt sie was es
bedeutet mit der vergangenheit zu
brechen ihnen einen schönen sonntag und
bleiben sie 18
[Musik]